[Music]
twitch is such a funny story because
justin khan who's himself now
like this
b2b
content creator you know person and has
stayed very true to his roots yeah
sweet guy super sweet guy also amazing
guy yeah and i've gotten to work with
him in a couple different capacities but
if you go back in time this is like
early
y combinator and y combinator at the
time was sort of viewed as kind of this
weird like why would you even do that
and it's like all these kids in it and
it's sort of maybe for people that
aren't legit obviously they've they've
completely proven that
what what an amazing idea it was at the
time and so justin's project at that
point was called justin tv
and he basically would just go and
wear this backpack
that had a laptop that had all had
connected to all the cellular networks
and it was kind of like all multiplexed
together so you get maximum bandwidth
and then that laptop then connected into
a hat like a camera that sat on his hat
and he would just live stream
his entire life
24 7. i think this went on for months
months and months and months
and the funny thing about justin and
doing that is it was just if you were
working in tech at the time and you were
like what's justin up to you would pull
up justin tv and you would say oh he's
doing the exact same same thing that i'm
doing which is just staring at a monitor
you know coding or whatever and it was
like a little bit of a critique of your
own life actually is what what it turned
into
but he he just did that and um for for
many years and um sorry for it for many
months and he ended up basically
realizing like okay you could build a
much more interesting company by
allowing people anybody to stream
not just justin obviously but you can
think of you know going back to that
atomic network concept the atomic
network was justin and his view his
nerdy viewers including myself there and
so he said okay well let's let's build
that out and so
him and his co-founders which include
kyle who eventually started cruise very
amazing guy michael cybel who eventually
is a president at y combinator
i mean his whole crew all really
impressive people basically started to
work on a platform where anybody could
stream anything and the thing is it kind
of worked but not really i remember
using the product during that period and
and when interviewing them they were
basically saying yeah people would just
stream pirated nfl games and that was
one of the major cases and
then other people would would try to
stream other kinds of you know weird
things like people are cooking or
they're you know they're just doing like
random stuff
and and the most interesting thing of of
you know and that went on for for
several years and they got to a point
where it was just kind of growing and
they were feeling
weird about it and should they go and
work on another company or should they
start a new company
and they ended up working on a couple
new ideas at once and one of them ended
up being to take the really really
narrow set of stream
streamers
that were part of justin tv that were
focused on games
and they just decided okay well why
don't we
make a bunch of changes all at once like
let's first of all make
all the streams
just about games and i think
at that point they said that
gaming was maybe only five percent of
justin tv so it wasn't like an obvious
thing to do
the second thing they did was rather
than making it about the viewers because
streaming is so much about viewing
instead let's make it all about creators
what are what's the creator's incentive
in doing all this
and so they ended up basically making it
about monetization and one of the
interviews that i had with emmett um
who's now ceo of twitch he talked about
this which is it's amazing what happens
when you are able to give any creator
someone on the internet 50 bucks you
know for us it you may think oh well
what's 50 bucks but for them it's just
like it it's like a huge aha moment
to go from creating content just purely
for follows and likes and views
to being able to monetize it at all 50
bucks to a point where maybe every time
you log in you know that you're going to
make
a bunch of money and then being able to
go professional is kind of like the next
level up from there
and
and so they ended up basically spinning
this off as its own separate property
and and amazingly it was like very very
in a very interesting journey because it
was became all about league of legends
for a long time like it was just about
watching you know people run that
tournament and then eventually
amazon bought them i mean it was i think
a steal
for just under a billion dollars i
forget which year it was of the company
but it's probably like year like five or
six or something of the company
and i think everyone thinks of twitch as
kind of like this weird overnight
success
when in reality you see all the like
stops and starts along the way
you know for it to become the success
that it is
do you have any insight into how they
made the decision to focus on gaming
there must have been some rationale
behind it
do you know why
yeah i think they were just seeing um
and i think this is true of a lot of
these network effect driven companies
that
it's not just one network it's actually
a lot of different networks kind of all
under one roof right so if you think
about what twitch or what justin tv was
at the time it was gaming but it was
also
sports and it was also creative stuff
and it was also you know all these other
things and
i think the the most interesting part of
the early data
was that they saw that there was just so
much more engagement in this narrow
niche and so even though it wasn't clear
that this was going to be a big idea and
this is for a long time people just
didn't understand twitch they could see
that there was a small group of people
that were just like fanatical about it
and so if you chase that often then you
can kind of
expand that goodness
and maybe there's a whole product that's
just about that and i think that's often
very counterintuitive because especially
when you're at a bigger company
you end up being very oriented around
like can this be big enough can this
move the needle enough
and you you end up not chasing these
little things which is what one of the
amazing parts that a startup can
actually do is they can just focus very
much on on that and expand from there
well the other you know aspect of this
that that hops to mind for me and and
please feel free to dismantle this if
this is
not
sort of plausible observation but
is
it seems
consistently underestimated how much
a good company
service can expand the market
right so in the case of twitch it's by
virtue of creating these tools and
catering to
creators
they increase the number of people drawn
to create right
so in other words if you were to look at
the
market analysis of what that could
become
prior to them creating all these tools
it would be somewhat misleading in the
same way that a lot of people i mean
hundreds of people said no to funding
uber on angel list
because because they said well how big
is the current you know total
addressable market of black sedans
really
and then if you only get
five percent of that that's a tiny
company
of course
not taking into account that the
existence of the technology
and enabling everyone to become or many
people to become drivers automatically
multiplies the size of that pie over and
over and over and over again that's
right well and and i think if you really
look at it
twitch
unlock the ability i mean i think twitch
and
patreon
and sub stack and there's a couple of
these companies that are now kind of
part of the
creator economy
really
reinvented i think the the just really
made it so that people could think wow
like instead of starting a small
business
doing the kinds of things that people
did back in the day you know you open a
small coffee shop or you do whatever
it's like you know you can you can make
millions of dollars a year
being a content creator on the internet
and it really solves i think something
that i think that has been called the
original sin
of the internet which is that we have an
advertising based system right like how
much of the privacy issues that people
talk about and the targeting you know
all the stuff that's been been happening
is really because
we decided to go with banner ads instead
of having people pay each other online
and and i think we we're kind of in this
really interesting point
of the ecosystem where we're able to
kind of unlock that there was a really
funny poll that lego actually ran where
they surveyed a bunch of kids it was
like 3 000 kids and asked them what are
the professions that they wanted to do
and and if you look at the results maybe
it's both funny and maybe maybe uh
dystopian that very high up on the list
the first thing on the list is being a
youtuber
is actually like the top job wow and it
was above uh teacher athlete musician
and then the last one on the list was
being an astronaut so no one wants to be
an astronaut they want to be youtubers
this might be this might be bad but like
um but but it is really interesting and
and i think twitch actually was so early
in all this because they built all these
tools exactly what you're saying
they basically became a way for people
to earn a new kind of living right which
is amazing because instead of
not everyone wants to drive a car not
everyone wants to
you know deliver food or sell beanie
babies on the internet but like there
are
new kinds of work that are forming and
if these kinds of work are more
compelling you get paid more they're
more interesting
than
a lot of the hourly work that we have in
america well you know what's going to
happen is like a lot of people are going
to try to be these things
and this whole technology layer is going
to support this new type of
work that's going to emerge and so we
often think of kind of the information
age as very much like a white collar
kind of
um
you know so you sit at a desk and you
know you're writing documents or
whatever but i think that actually a lot
of this will probably lead to a ton of
jobs being created a lot of work being
created that's of ultimately a creative
nature yeah and then that may be really
what people are more excited about than
you know then doing the kind of hourly
work that's available
you